tous les arbres des tableaux ont des
histoires à te raconter
et si tu m'écoutes très attentivement
je te dirai tout leur secret
ils existent depuis des millions
d'années les arbres ont vu naître les
hommes et la civilisation des vieux
sages témoins muets de notre histoire
qui ont inspiré le peintre Grataloup
tout au long de sa vie que savons-nous
sur eux l'exposition les arbres mondiaux
au musée Grataloup de Chevreuse apporte
quelques éléments de réponse j'ai
imaginé en fait tout un parcours où les
en faisant parler les arbres et pour qui
nous explique combien ils sont
importants pour nous pour vivre c'était
le peintre de la nature grâce à l'eau il
peignait bien sûr avant tout la nature
et dans la nature et ce qui est de plus
important ce sont les arbres c'est toute
cette histoire à travers ses siècles de
vie finalement parce que nous humains on
est tout petit à côté des arbres une
exposition didactique qui sensibilise
sur le besoin urgent de préserver notre
planète et sa biodiversité elle a été
pensée lors de multiples incendies qui
ont ravagé les forêts lors de l'été 2022
j'étais au bord de l'océan et autour de
moi les sapins brûlaient et j'étais
absolument effrayée par ses sapins qui
brûlaient et j'ai pensé à normal qu'elle
avait fait grâce à nous parce que
Grataloup c'est un précurseur en fait
c'est des au-delà du Précurseur c'était
quelqu'un qui sentait toujours les
choses arriver avant qu'elle n'arrivait
j'ai pensé que il fallait faire quelque
chose pour les arbres c'était une sorte
de plaidoyer pour les arbres c'était
qu'on prenne conscience que ils sont la
vie et la vie bien avant nous donc bon
là je crois que ça parle d'elle-même
vous voyez donc la forêt avant le feu et
la forêt au moment du feu et pour se
ressourcer le musée ne propose pas de
câliner un arbre comme la silvothérapie
le suggère mais elle accueille en
revanche dans ses jardins les oeuvres de
l'artiste peintre énergéticienne c'était
la brillant j'exposition en fait les 7
couleurs des sept chakras que j'ai
réalisé sur du bois d'azobe qui a un
bois exotique qui est utilisé pour la
construction des planches de Deauville
chaque chakra à une spécificité en fait
et moi je la retranscris par les
spirales que je réalise le but c'est que
les gens qui viennent visiter cette
exposition bien prennent du temps pour
se placer devant chaque œuvre et
reçoivent en fait un soin un soin
d'amour et un soin qui correspond à la
couleur qu'ils ont envie de voir
l'exposition est ouverte jusqu'au 5
novembre 2023 elle propose aux plus
jeunes un podcast adapté pendant la
visite de quoi on apprend plus sur ses
grands végétaux en plein cœur du parc
national de la Vallée de Chevreuse
[Musique]